well since you guys really seem to dig
this the first time around I'll do it
again I don't know why this just feels
right there butter knives by the way
x-men Days of Future past came out this
weekend and before I go any further I
want to warn you this is a spoiler
filled review I have an original review
posted on my channel that is spoiler
free if you want to check that one out
instead go to that now because I'm about
to talk about all kinds of stuff I got
to see x-men Days of Future past again
tonight I actually went to the drive-in
theater with my fiance was a lot of fun
sometimes to do that when it gets warmer
outside there's a drive-in somewhat
close to our house we'll see you for
like the first time at a screening but
then we'll go to the drive-in for the
second viewing so we got to kind of
relax and you know keep back in the car
it's nice or stars around everything and
you see Wolverines but yeah that's a big
spoiler at least it was from my fiance
anyway because she certainly enjoyed
that scene damn Hugh Jackman so you guys
know that I really love this movie and I
loved it because not only did it have
really awesome action sequences but it
had such a good emotional core to it in
which all of the major characters were
affected by this one central story and
one of the things I actually really
liked about the movie and that surprised
me at first was Wolverine wasn't really
like ultimate hardcore badass dude in
this movie he had to work against the
grain he had to have peaceful thoughts
as he continues to try to tell himself
during the first act of this movie
because he was the person in this movie
that had to bring all these people
together and he couldn't do that with
his claws he had to use his brain he had
to use his heart and that was a really
cool thing to see because you got to see
a different side of Wolverine a more
experienced more used to the grind
Wolverine who just wants to help and
that was a really cool way to view his
character because we got to see the
really cool berserk badass Wolverine in
the Wolverine that came out last year so
it's cool to see a much more mellow
reserved version and yes I did enjoy
that scene in the beginning where he
tears apart those guys and he like wakes
up he doesn't know where he is so much
good humor was also thrown throughout
this film a lot of it due to the time
period it kind of reminded me of Star
Trek for a voyage home where the entire
Star Trek crew goes back to modern days
and they're like confused about where
they are it was a sort of different take
on the fish out of the water thing
because he was around people he knows
it's just that he doesn't really know
them yet so there were so many cool
character nuances that could come out of
that and this film took a lot of benefit
from that let's talk about the biggest
ones first the ones you guys probably
want to hear me talk about the most this
film kind of alters the timeline of the
previous x-men films particularly x-men
3 because that was the one that Bryan
Singer was going to direct and then
ended up doing Superman Returns why dude
why'd you do that you should just
directed x-men 3 it's almost like he
knows that now because he's back doing
another x-men film trying to erase
certain things that happen in x-men 3
it's like he's like yeah I probably
should have done it the first time after
the timeline is altered we see Jean Grey
again and not only her but Cyclops is
back and I didn't want to mention this
in my original review but really ever do
I scream or shout or say anything really
during a film but when Cyclops came
on-screen I literally went oh I was
like I shouldn't said that like I was
like oh I want to be quiet cuz I hate
when people do that but it just was like
oh gosh Cyclops is back because that was
one of those disappointing things about
x-men 3 to me because it's Cyclops
I love Cyclops like why are you just
kill off Iron Man or something
it's Cyclops and it was so cool to see
Cyclops back in this movie and I know
that some fans of x-men 3 are
disappointed by the fact that that
timeline is now basically crushed but
you know what I like it Cyclops is back
one of my favorite scenes in this film
is the scene in which magneto finally
decides you know what I'm not going to
have any more of this the younger
version Michael Fox Bender's version and
he decides to ambush everyone and
sabotage everyone by using his powers to
shoot a bullet through the air into
mystique and then you get like these
really great inserts of 1970s cameras
capturing it and you're like you like
feel the horror of it almost as if you
are there and like that's what you would
see on the news or whatever of that
event I thought that whole scene was
very intense the way it all played along
and there was a moment where Logan lost
his memory where I was like wait are
they really gonna do this memory loss
thing that usually doesn't work and
gratefully it was just for that one
scene one of the things I loved about
this movie was how it gave you an
opportunity to see a lot of character
deaths that you were like storms dying
and Bishop and Iceman and everyone
they're all just dying what's going on
Colossus got ripped in half it was like
when the dinosaurs in lost world
tore that Gaiden too but because the
altered timeline thing they were able to
take advantage of those dramatic scenes
and then have them actually be back at
the end so it was kind of cool it was
like they were able to see what it would
be like of all these characters did die
but then you had that moment where
Wolverine just walking around seeing
everyone and you're like okay it's all
back to normal and you can definitely
tell that Bryan Singer made this film
thinking like okay look my films that I
made those x-men films those are my
films and someone came along and did
stuff I don't like that I'm gonna revert
it to the way I had it and you know in a
way you could look at that and say
that's kind of dickish but I like his
story of x-men I like the way he handles
the characters and so I am fine with it
the one thing that did confuse me about
the movie is at the end of the Wolverine
he has his bone claws and then the
beginning of this one he's got his
adamantium back again so I don't really
know I'm assuming that they've just kind
of had to deal with that inconsistency
because they were filming the film's
pretty close back-to-back so I don't
really know about that one there that's
a little confusing to me one of the
biggest questions of this movie and
obviously it's not the kind of question
that can be answered immediately because
it ends on a cliffhanger where mystique
is impersonating Stryker now if you know
anything about the other films Stryker
is the person who got Wolverine his
adamantium all throughout his body
if mystique is impersonating him white
like I just brain explosion I don't even
know what that means so we're gonna have
to see the end credits scene features a
very small apocalypse now I'm gonna be
honest here don't know much about the
character of apocalypse I do however
know that he's gigantic so I don't know
actually I it was just nice to have an
actual end credits scene after the
amazing spider-man 2 just had like a
promotional spot for the x-men Days of
Future past it was cool to actually have
a end credits scene that mattered
Jennifer Lawrence in this movie as
mystique just blew my mind I mean I
enjoyed her in first class she was good
but she just didn't have the Flair and
the intensity that Rebecca remains
Stamos had for the action element of
mystique she was good as mystique she
captured the emotion and like the fear
of that character but she wasn't as cool
I guess in this film she was
awesome but she also retained that
emotion and I gotta say the scene where
she's like she's got the guy trapped
against the wall and she's just standing
there with her leg on him I was just I
was an enjoyable scene for me the
interplay between James McAvoy and
Michael Fassbender in this movie is
fantastic the scene on the plane where
they just have that argument where you
can actually understand both sides like
it's one of those really great ways that
you can actually relate to a villain the
best villains in film are the ones you
were like you know what I actually
understand where he's coming from with
the Joker in the Dark Knight makes sense
everything he says makes sense Darth
Vader in the original Star Wars films
you understand why he is as messed up as
he is even before the prequels you
understood that in the films because it
was portrayed so well you understand why
magneto is pissed and you understand why
Xavier is pissed it all works together
because he has that great scene where
he's yelling is like all those all of
our brothers are dead and you didn't do
anything to help us in some ways you can
actually kind of side with magneto a
little bit and so you can kind of
understand where he's coming from the
scenes with Quicksilver were incredible
and as I said in my original review that
scene that I think is one of the best
scenes I've ever seen in a comic book
film was the scene where you see in slow
motion he's running in circles around
the guys he's positioning their arms to
punch themselves in the face he's moving
the bullets not only was it very funny
but it was visually brilliant
Quicksilver in this movie was fantastic
I would have loved to see more of his
character I can understand why he wasn't
around though because he'd basically
beat everyone like instantly like when
magneto was doing everything with a gun
he'd just go like oh I got it
sorry you lose overall x-men Days of
Future past is a very great blockbuster
because it has all those really awesome
action scenes that are done well but it
also has such a great emotional core to
it and I love the way they fix certain
things that I was kind of upset about
from the other x-men films we can
actually start fresh now and have some
of these characters back I'm assuming
they're going to find other interesting
and humor filled ways to progress this
series because Wolverine now has this
knowledge Xavier has this knowledge and
I'm wondering how magneto
is going to play into all that and of
course the ending with mystique and
personating Stryker and can't wait to
see how they played that out as well
what did you guys think of x-men Days of
Future past I had a great time with this
movie and from what I'm hearing quite a
bit of other people did as well thanks
as always for watching guys and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck
nice